c'était trop tard pour sauver les océans
un peu partout à travers le monde des
scientifiques et des citoyens s'unissent
pour trouver des solutions mais cela
prendra des efforts considérables
notamment pour se défaire de notre
dépendance aux plastiques
il faudra aussi une volonté ferme des
dirigeants de la planète pour éviter le
pire
les océans n'ont jamais été aussi
malmené et les conséquences pour
l'avenir de l'humanité se font déjà
sentir
c'est pourquoi les nations unies ont
proclamé que cette décennie sera celle
des sciences océaniques au service du
développement durable
devant l'urgence les scientifiques du
monde entier seront mis à contribution
pour tenter d'inverser le déclin des
océans avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
ce sentiment d'urgence a trouvé écho à
columbus en ohio
c'est là qu'habite cathy s'enlever
l'astronaute et océanographes nous a
donné rendez vous aux cossaye le centre
de sciences qu'elle a dirigé et où ses
prouesses sont immortalisés
mais quand pareil dans la navette ont
pris ces photos si c'est lors de ce vol
à bord de la navette challenger en 1984
que cathy sans heaven inscrit son nom
dans le grand livre de la vente sur
aérospatiale des états unis si elles
fâchent qu'indique chez la première
femme américaine à marcher dans l'espace
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'un début
cathy steven va ensuite réalisé deux
autres missions spatiales
avant d'être nommé scientifique en chef
de l'anneau à la prestigieuse agence
américaine responsable de l'étude de
l'océan et de l'atmosphère
à ce moment là scientifique comprend
qu'elle peut faire une réelle différence
âgées sentais vraiment que selon de voir
cette opportunité fantastique de voir
notre propre planète de ce point de vue
il faut que je retourne sur terre et
trouver les moyens de remporter cette
perspective a les jambes je dis en
anglais
mais quand même
[Musique]
mais le goût de l'aventuré n'est jamais
bien loin en 2020 cathy son neveu est
invité à plonger à bord de ce merci bhl
dans la fosse des mariannes
l'objectif descendre jusqu'au point
nommé charles jeudi l'endroit le plus
profond jamais mesuré dans les océans à
plus de dix mille neuf cent mètres sous
le niveau de la mer
j'ai lu beaucoup de papier des livres au
sujet de tchaoudjo disent même d'être là
le voir moi-même mes yeux si on peut pas
résister je ne peux pas résister bien
sûr j'y vais
elle devient alors le premier être
humain à avoir marché dans l'espace et à
s'être aussi rendu au point le plus
profond des océans une expédition hors
du commun et c'est comme un ascenseur
quatre heures dans un ascenseur serine
calme général les rares humains qui
s'aventurent à ces profondeurs ont droit
à tout un spectacle
c'est ça qu'il est pour moi la magie
klaus y en partout dans nos cieux on
trouve la vie
tous les espèces tout l'équipe tous les
formes que les adaptations de la vie
partout dans notion c'est un miracle si
merveilleuse et puis on est arrivé sur
le fond c'était comme le paysage de la
lune mais les fosses abyssales réserve
aussi de triste surprise on a trouvé le
plastique au plus profond région de
lotion on est en profondeur de 11 mm au
centre de noël et quand même les déchets
humaines sont sentis arriver partout
nous les hommes ne sont partout sur
terre nous sommes partout dans notion
les humains sont ils allés trop loin
dans son rapport sur l'océan
le groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat le giec crois
qu'il est encore possible de sauver la
mise
plus nous agirons rapidement et de
manière décisive
plus nous serons en mesure de faire face
aux changements inévitables et d'assurer
la durabilité des écosystèmes et des
populations du monde entier
l'appel a été entendu en gaspésie les
pêcheurs sont conscients de l'ampleur de
la tâche mais il croit qu'il est
toujours possible de changer la donne
un examen c'est ce que beaucoup changé
nos habitudes de vie pas mal tout le
monde qui a changé soit à base de
données plus je te dise pas que ça va
durer encore un million d'années
mais au moins pour faire des pieds ainsi
de préserver la continuité partout sur
la planète des initiatives voient le
jour pour tenter d'enrayer le déclin des
socios en floride par exemple des
scientifiques ont réussi à reproduire
une espèce de corail en laboratoire il
pense être en mesure de restaurer les
récifs de coraux nécessaires à la vie
marine et qui sont menacées de
disparition des programmes de
certifications ont été créés ici et
ailleurs pour aider les consommateurs à
choisir des poissons et des fruits de
mer pêchés ou produits de façon durable
de nouvelles technologies sont aussi
développées pour débarrasser les océans
du plastique et partout des corvées sont
organisés pour nettoyer les plages et
les fonds marins
à san diego en californie l'océanographe
sarah-jane royer a justement décidé de
passer à l'action pour contrer cette
pollution causée par les déchets
plastiques donc ici on va sélectionner
les petits bouts microplastiques elle et
son conjoint élabore une application
pour téléphone mobile qui mise sur la
participation citoyenne et
l'intelligence artificielle les citoyens
vont prendre des photos de bouts de
plastique sur des plages sont des roches
sur les zones côtières en général ces
photos vont être partagé avec nous puis
à l'aide de l'algorithme on va calculer
les concentrations de plastique à
travers le monde mais tous ces efforts
citoyens ne seront pas suffisants il
faut que les pays travaillent ensemble
sur un but commun parce que tous ces
problèmes ils sont plus grands que
chaque pays ils sont plus grands que le
plus grand pays
il s'agit de tout leur prête il faudra
l'action commun de toute l'humanité
un exemple de ce que peuvent faire les
nations c'est la création d'aires
marines protégées des zones où les
activités humaines sont strictement
encadrées et où la pêche est souvent
interdite
les aires marines protégées une fois
qu'elles sont créées elles produisent
plus de poissons pour les pêcheurs qui
travaillent dans les dents les ongles
non protégés et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on quitte bien établies partout il y
a encore du travail à faire au canada et
pour l'ensemble de la planète
moins de 10% des zones côtières et
océaniques bénéficie du statut des aires
marines protégées
malgré ces aires protégées
la pression demeure forte sur le milieu
marin
à preuve ottawa vient d'autoriser
l'industrie pétrolière a effectué 40
forage exploratoire en mer au large de
terre-neuve une région pourtant reconnue
par l'onu pour son importance écologique
et biologique
le gouvernement doit se baser sur la
science si un gouvernement ne se base
pas sur la science c'est le chaos aérien
de marche et c'est pour ça que les
ressources se casse la figure partout
le chaos peut-être évité des étoiles aux
fosses abyssales
le parcours de 409 'on lui permet de
croire en un avenir meilleur
et ce sont les nouvelles générations qui
devront montrer la route
je dirais aux jeunes que votre
créativité votre intelligence votre
passion on en a besoin
le printemps en a besoin elle le dira
que toi tu as l'occasion
c'est ici que du vie tout est unifiée
avec tout cela alors tu peux faire une
différence il faut vraiment que de façon
différente ont leur revers et travailler
fort et vas-y
[Musique]
oui
à